à 18h15 sur public sénat bonjour vous
allez poursuivre dans un instant
l'audition de marie christine saragosse
la président de l'audiovisuel extérieur
de la france
elle était auditionné ici au sénat par
la commission de la culture dans le
cadre de l'examen du projet de loi sur
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel public
nonce paolini et remy fine 1 les patrons
de tf1 et de france télévisions ont
également été entendu par les sénateurs
ainsi qu'aurélie filippetti la ministre
de la culture
l'objectif de ce texte est de revenir
sur le mode de désignation des patrons
des radios et télévisions publiques
une mesure particulièrement controversée
du quinquennat nicolas sarkozy alors
désormais les présidents de
l'audiovisuel public seront nommés par
le conseil supérieur de l'audiovisuel
voilà et ce texte sera examiné ici au
sénat début octobre
madame la présidente nous sommes très
heureux de vous accueillir et nous vous
remercions d'avoir répondu à notre
invitation
vous êtes là vous le savez dans le cadre
d'une audition préparatoire donc à 1 aux
travaux par qui sont relatifs à la loi
sur l'audiovisuel qui va venir en
discussion à partir du 2 octobre
prochain
cette loi qui donc s'intitule
l'indépendance de l'audiovisuel public
donc c'est dans ce cadre là que nous
avons souhaité vous entendre à la fois
pour que vous nous fassiez part
peut-être de votre lecture de vos
interrogations de vos réflexions
et puis peut-être que nous fassiez un
point sur la présidence et dans votre
maison de france mediamath voilà je donc
après votre intervention
david assouline qui est le rapporteur
pour cette loi vous interrogera et puis
la parole après sera donné à nos
collègues sénatrices et sénateurs
merci merci beaucoup madame la
présidente
alors je pense qu'il ne m'appartient pas
de commenter une loi qui touche même
indirectement mon propre statut c'est un
petit peu difficile mais en revanche
peut-être dire un mot d'ailleurs de mes
conditions de nomination parce que ça
faisait il ya tout juste un an près
quelques jours près que je que je
passais en commission des affaires
culturelles ici même après être passé à
l'assemblée nationale et est repassée
d'ailleurs devant le csa lors par
rapport à la législation antérieure ggb
des fils et d'une d'une étape
supplémentaire qui allait dans le sens
de la future loi puisque le président de
la république avait demandé au csa de
désigner un candidat qu'il allait à son
tour désigné pour suivre le parcours de
nomination des présidents
alors moi j'ai trouvé ça plutôt plus
confortable d'être désigné par le par le
csa et jeu donc je pense que je peux
quand même dire que ça va dans le bon
sens ce que j'ai trouvé très important
aussi c'est de passer justement devant
l'assemblée nationale et le sénat devant
les commissions des affaires culturelles
et
et d'ailleurs d'avoir un vote qui marque
qui m'a touché puisqu'il était pas tout
à fait unanime mais presque et qui
montrait que bien que ce soit un décret
du président de la république qui me
désigne mon ma désignation a été assez
consensuel et elles étaient donc fondées
sur des critères professionnels ce qui
est le cas aussi de mes collègues
présidents des deux autres sociétés
nationales de programme
donc je je trouve que dans le processus
futur c'est le csa lui-même qui va
bénéficier au fond les membres du csa
qui vont bénéficier de cette désignation
par par des commissions ce qui est une
chose importante
et puis j'ai vu également que deux mois
je crois après la désignation le le
futur pdg serait amenée à remettre un
premier document d'orientation sur sa
stratégie aux commissions des assemblées
et qui pourra être auditionné sur cette
base je trouve que c'est important que
c'est une étape de la loi importante
c'est bien un document d'orientation ça
n'est pas encore un plan stratégique et
c'est important aussi parce que en tout
cas pour ce qui me concerne je trouve
très important que le plan stratégique
soit l'émanation pas seulement d'une
personne mais de l'ensemble de
l'entreprise et j'ai essayé de bâtir un
plan stratégique dans une démarche très
participative et qui est en même temps
une formation pour quand on arrive dans
une entreprise qu'on ne connaît pas il
faut avoir l'humilité de la découvrir
et donc après ma nomination qui était le
j'ai pris mes fonctions le 8 octobre
dernier
j'ai organisé des séminaires le samedi
sur base de volontariat où on a eu
jusqu'à 400 participants selon les
médias on avait vraiment une très forte
participation une participation a écrite
et j'ai pu donc construire un plan
stratégique qu'on a restitué aux
salariés en janvier
et c'est sur cette base que j'ai que
j'ai pu saisir l'état nos tutelles pour
discuter notre futur comme je trouve que
c'était donc important
c'est bon ça remarche
oui parce que quand même je travaille
dans les médias je sens quand quand le
bruit émis je sais que ça veut dire que
son montant
donc voilà donc je pense qu à la fois
c'est très important qu'ils aient un
premier document d'orientation
stratégique mais ça doit être un
document d'orientation et que l'on
puisse laisser ensuite le temps au pdg
de de bâtir un plan partagé par les
salariés donc ça c'était un premier
point que je voulais peut-être évoqué
par rapport à la prochaine loi alors ce
que je ce que je voudrais dire aussi
c'est que l'indépendance qui est le
sujet de la loi ne se résume pas pour
moi aux modalités de désignation d'un du
pdg alors j'ai un peu pris ça comme un
sujet de philosophie qu'est ce que
l'indépendance c'est le levain être
alors je me suis dit que on va voir si
on dit des choses qui se recoupent
je me suis dit que c'était peut-être un
équilibre entre liberté responsabilité
et confiance alors liberté jeu dans dans
des médias comme comme ceux que je
dirige c'est d'autant plus important que
ce sont des médias d'information qui
sont constitués autour de rédaction donc
la liberté d'informer c'est un pilier de
ces médias d'ailleurs c'est peut-être un
impayé de notre démocratie française
j'insiste sur français parce que nous
sommes confrontés partout dans le monde
à des endroits où la liberté d'informer
n'existe pas et il m'arrive fréquemment
d'avoir des journalistes blessées ou
emprisonnées donc jeu c'est important de
revenir sur cette cette idée qui nous
est peut être naturelle mais qu'il n'est
pas partout dans le monde et ça ne
progresse pas nécessairement
donc cette liberté d'informer
d'expression de nos médias
elle n'est pas elle ne peut pas être
l'émanation de la politique des
gouvernements français s'est d'ailleurs
inscrit dans notre cahier des charges et
c'est très important pour notre
crédibilité mondiale et en plus
d'ailleurs ce serait bien difficile
parce que il ya soixante six
nationalités qui se côtoient dans france
médias monde 14 langues et donc
forcément il n'y a pas qu'un seul point
de vue qui s'exprime et c'est la
richesse de ceux de cet outil c'est
aussi peut-être d'ailleurs une signature
française de permettre l'expression de
tous les points de vue et de les laisser
s'exprimer sur nos médias c'est ce qui
fait notre crédibilité dans le monde des
jeux ça n'empêche pas un socle de
valeurs communes qui doit faire l'objet
d'une charte je pense que ça c'est aussi
un élément de d'indépendance important
de se mettre tous ensemble d'accord sur
un certain nombre de deux principes
comme l'honnêteté dans l'exposé des
faits ou le pluralisme la liberté des
consciences
ça c'est aussi une idée neuve hors de
nos frontières
la laïcité les droits humains l'égalité
des hommes et des femmes la promotion de
la diversité ce sont autant de valeurs
auxquelles on peut adhérer sans être
pour autant l'émanation d'un
gouvernement et à côté de ça il ya aussi
toute une série de règles dans le
traitement de l'information qui nous
renvoie d'ailleurs au deuxième point
pour moi d'indépendance et aussi la
responsabilité et pour nos médias encore
plus
enfin pour tous les médias c'est vrai
mais quand on est à l'international et
qu'on aimait dans des endroits où on est
en situation de crise il faut aussi être
responsable quand on prend la parole et
qu'on a un outil médiatique puissant
puisqu'on peut infléchir le cours des
choses et mettre en danger la vie de nos
concitoyens donc c'est une
responsabilité ça fait partie aussi de
notre indépendance plus on est
responsable plus de contenus sont
irréprochables crédible et plus on est
indépendant mais la responsabilité je
mets aussi dense dans ce concept de le
fait de rendre compte
parce qu'on est des médias publics qu'on
est financé sur des fonds publics et
qu'il est légitime donc de rendre compte
de rendre compte demain au csa qui
désignera les pdg mais aussi au conseil
d'administration et à nos tutelles et
aussi au parlement ça fait partie de la
vie de médiate c'est parfaitement
légitime après je pense que il faut
ajouter immédiatement le zeste de
conscience qui fait que cette cette
capacité à rendre compte ne se
transforme pas en une espèce de
surveillance continue et de
justification continue il faut pouvoir
aussi agir donc la confiance réciproque
entre l'actionnaire qui peut que je pars
de l'actionnaire au sens le plus large
c'est à dire que j'inclus le parlement
et et l'état dans son ensemble dans
toutes ses composantes comme actionnaire
l'actionnaire à un moment il doit nous
faire confiance aussi donc il s'agit à
travers par exemple un contrat
d'objectif et moyens de partager une
stratégie des objectifs mais aussi de
s'assurer de financement parce qu'il n'y
a pas d'indépendance sans sans sécurité
de des financements qui nous permette
d'exercer nos missions est de réaliser
nos objectifs et dans des médias
d'information c'est une donnée
particulièrement importante parce que si
nous dépendons trop fortement d'un
financement sur le marché
parrainage publicité jeu je pense que
l'indépendance se définit aussi par
rapport aux puissances d'argent pas
seulement par rapport au pouvoir
politique et que c'est quand on est par
exemple on sait très bien qu'un jour un
journal en droit français ne peut pas
être parrainés c'est bien légitime mais
elle va plus loin il peut être difficile
d'avoir une émission médicale qui serait
parrainé par enfin un laboratoire
pharmaceutique il ya une déontologie
même du choix des recettes publicitaires
qui pèse encore plus fortement quand on
est un média d'information
c'est pourquoi les financements publics
ont une importance encore plus grande
quand on est un média d'information et
et ses financements publics pour qu'ils
soient le plus stable possible
ben c'est intéressant qu'il soit fléché
ça tombe bien puisqu'on a une recette
fléché donc je sais qu'elle a changé de
nom mais je dirais redevance encore
c'est important d'avoir un financement
de ce type qui est un gage
d'indépendance en réalité alors dans ce
cadre-là l'audiovisuel extérieur n'a pas
toujours été totalement inclus dans la
réflexion puisqu'une grande partie de
financements viennent de subventions jeu
pour ma part je pense que la question
avait d'être posée est ce qu'un
financement par redevance de
l'audiovisuel extérieur n'est pas une
nécessité d dès lors la question de la
réforme de la redevance se pose puisque
aujourd'hui telle quelle elle ne permet
probablement pas aux trois opérateurs de
l'audiovisuel public de de vivre
correctement et de remplir leur mission
il se trouve que la redevance en france
est une des plus basses d'europe
en tout cas comparativement à la taille
de notre service public je pense qu'elle
est plus basse encore en grèce mais on
sait ce qui peut arriver quand la
redevance est très très basse pour des
services publics donc je vois là je
pense qu'il est donc important de
réfléchir à cette ressource et je sais
que vous le faites d'ailleurs qu'il faut
pas exclure donc l'audiovisuel extérieur
de cette réflexion nous avons travaillé
donc sur ce plan stratégique dont je
parle et nous sommes nous avons vraiment
eu un travail extrêmement confiants et
constructif avec l'état avec les
tutelles
mais l'état y sont contraintes
budgétaires fortes donc
si on est ambitieux sur le plan
international il faut aussi qu'ils aient
des recettes en face notre notre
dotation y compris sur le financement de
redevances et public représente et ce
même si j'inclus tv5monde qui fait
partie aussi de l'action de audiovisuel
extérieur ça représente quand même moins
de 9 % du budget total de l'audiovisuel
public français donc si ça reste à cette
proportion très bien mais il faudrait
que ça s'applique à un gâteau un petit
peu plus grand dans ce cas là voilà ce
que je voulais vous dire sur le sur la
notion d'indépendance
si je reviens sur il ya un point
également dans l'indépendance qui est
important c'est probablement la
stabilité il faut qu'on ait un certain
temps pour pour ne pas se sentir de
nouveau en situation d'être redésigné
donc je pense que la durée des mandats
ou la stabilité des stratégistes un
point important aussi
donc en tout cas pour ce qui nous
concerne les relations avec l'état
aujourd'hui son sont très satisfaisantes
le travail convient de compte on est
encore en train de finir sur notre
projet de contrat d'objectifs et de
moyens a été une refondation je pense
dans nos rapports avec l'état avec les
tutelles avec le conseil
d'administration
par ailleurs nos relations avec le
parlement sont également assez intense
on voit beaucoup de parlementaires et on
a lancé d'ailleurs des invitations aux
différentes commissions qui nous suivent
qui sèche des affaires étrangères ou de
la culture parce que outre la réponse au
questionnaire parlementaire qui est très
utile et qu'on fait du mieux qu'on peut
parfois le contact direct avec les
équipes in situ en quelque sorte je
pense que ça contribue à éclairer
les choses et à permettre aux
parlementaires de remplir également leur
contrôle au mieux donc on a lancé des
invitations pour toutes les commissions
concernées pour venir nous voir pour
ceux qui voudraient nos relations avec
le csa sont excellentes aussi et nous
avons souhaité les associer à notre
stratégie donc comme j'ai pu informer
mon conseil où certains parlementaires
de ce plan stratégique j'ai également
fait pour le le csa qui nous a fait
l'honneur dans son ensemble les neuf
membres actuels sont sont venus visiter
nos locaux et ont fait une réunion de
travail à bâtons rompus avec toute
l'équipe de direction
ça nous a d'ailleurs donné l'occasion
d'aborder également avec le csa la
question de notre présence en france qui
a pu être abordé par certains certains
intervenants que vous avez auditionné
alors je conçois que quand on est dans
le secteur privé qu'on trouve ses
financements sur le marché on soit
inquiet de toute modification de la
structure de financement et donc du
marché publicitaire en l'occurrence moi
quand je plaide la présence de nos
médias en france je m'inscris vraiment
dans une mission de service public et
même dans une mission sociétale de
construction de notre société pour
voyager beaucoup je sais que un service
public fort c c'est un gage d'abord d'un
certain niveau pour l'ensemble du
paysage audiovisuel national que quelque
part le service public donne le là qui
s'adresse à des citoyens et pas
seulement à des à des téléspectateurs ou
des auditeurs et que ça peut avoir une
importance quand comme nous comme nos
médias nous abordons des sujets qui ne
sont pas traitées au niveau national je
pense à france 24 qui est la seule
chaîne de service public d'information
continue avec un positionnement
éditorial mondiale ce qui à l'heure de
la mondialisation peut aussi intéresser
nos concitoyens c'est un positionnement
très différent des autres chaînes
d'information est par ailleurs
d'ailleurs france 24 ne pense pas se
financer sur le marché français
en revanche il est parfois délicat de ne
pas être par exemple sur la tnt en
france est de prétendre y être dans des
pays amis en côte d'ivoire au sénégal
ailleurs qu'ils connaissent parfaitement
le paysage audiovisuel national français
et s'étonne que nul ne soit prophète en
son pays mais souhaite l'être dans le
leur donc c'est je crois que france24
pourrait avoir au moins une fenêtre au
moins une présence régionale et c'est
une discussion que nous avons une façon
constructive avec l'état donc je laisse
à l'état le soin de dire ce qui ce qu'il
en a conclu
par ailleurs s'agissant de radio radio
france internationale est également une
radio remarquable c'est d'ailleurs une
discussion que j'ai eue avec jean luc
hess dans un dans une très grande
confraternité il est vain je veux pas
donc parler à sa place mais revoit en
tout cas il qu il trouvait en effet
qu'il y avait certains aspects de sa
d'une mission de service public d'une
raid de la radio nationale qui pouvaient
pas nécessairement être rempli par les
les médias seulement nationaux rfi a une
connaissance de l'international de
l'afrique afrique dont nous avons sur
notre territoire des ressortissants
qu'ils soient français d'origine
africaine ou africains et quand on voit
le travail que ferrer fit la
connaissance d'ailleurs des africains de
des enjeux internationaux quand on les
entend appeler notre antenne le matin
sur appels sur l'actualité
je pense que rfi fait vraiment oeuvre de
services publics et que dans certains
endroits
ce serait bien utile de la voir d'autant
que ça crée une distorsion entre
l'ile-de-france où la radio est présente
et les la province dans notre pays
centralisé
moi je suis une provinciale quand je
rentre chez moi je je n'entends pas à
rfi alors bien sûr j'ai mon iphone mais
tout le monde n'est pas en état
d'écoutés encore la radio sur les
nouveaux médias et